des chiffres qui ne cessent de
s'accroître si la vie normale reprend
peu à peu ses droits comme ici à sao
paulo
le virus continue de tuer avec plus d'un
million de cas et près de cinquante
mille morts
le brésil détient le bilan le plus
meurtrier sur la planète après les états
unis dans l'état de rio de janeiro ce
point de dépistage façon driving a été
installé pour tester les habitants
d'après des statistiques rapportées par
el país brésil ce territoire est
actuellement celui qui détient le plus
haut taux de mortalité du pays
parmi les populations les plus touchées
sur l'ensemble du sol brésilien figure
les communautés autochtones aux lignes
au paille à cannes caciques de la tribu
kayapos grands défenseurs de la forêt
amazonienne est lui-même décédé ducobu
19 il ya quelques jours
d'autres peuples indigènes s'en sortent
mieux face à la pandémie
mais préfère rester prudent il est
difficile pour nous d'éviter le contact
avec d'autres personnes
beaucoup de gens passent par cette
frontière mais y donner l'ordre aux gens
de ne pas aller dans d'autres endroits
dans d'autres communautés et de ne pas
recevoir des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur
c'est ainsi que nous vivons sans parler
à personne
[Musique]
il s'agit d'une population indigène qui
n'a aucun cas de kovy 19 et nous
répondons à ces besoins en pédiatrie
gynécologie orthopédie chirurgie et
cliniques médicales
tout ce dont elle a besoin pour établir
un diagnostic et fournir le meilleur
traitement possible la gestion de la
pandémie par jaillir ball so now est
vivement critiquée depuis l'arrivée du
virus
le président brésilien est régulièrement
accusé de ne pas avoir pris la juste
mesure de la crise l'ancien ministre de
la santé abonde dans ce sens un soldat
de la société brésilienne a de grandes
difficultés en matière de comportement
raison de la nature douteuse des
orientations
le ministère de la santé a demandé
renforcé avec les gouverneurs la
nécessité de l'isolément de la distance
le président de la république a dit
exactement le contraire il a démontré le
conte
r il a systématiquement briser ce
courant il a fait douter beaucoup de
gens il s'est toujours concentrée sur
l'économie et n'a jamais cherché à
préserver des vies
certains scientifiques redoutent une
sous-estimation des chiffres officiels
en raison du manque de test dans une
population qui compte près de 212
millions d'habitants